welcome back we are live
once uh again here we go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
[Music]
to your favorite podcast
oh
what's up y'all you know what my voice
is shot today I don't know
got a little sick
my title I don't know why my title thing
isn't showing up I don't know there's
always something y'all
but anyways welcome back to River
Griffin I'm sorry I don't have my normal
Golden Voice going and I don't know why
this thing isn't showing up but it is
what it is but anyways welcome back to
Riverwood Griffin today Met Gala NBA
news and notes I love American Idol and
today in the top eight I want to talk
about that my trip to the Mothership but
welcome back
[Music]
all right there it is a little bit
yeah where's my riffing with Griffin
title I don't understand that I don't
know guys there's always something with
this man makes no sense why that's not
showing up
makes no sense why this thing isn't
showing up like what wait what's going
on here you know what I mean I mean it's
like there's always something oh Wells
we did it we're back ladies and
gentlemen we are back welcome to riffing
with Griffin everybody
um we're from where Griffin is here you
know I'll just put this title up you
know remember Griffin go to
ourgirlfriend.com
for news and notes on my terrible
website
um you want to subscribe Please
Subscribe because that's how you'll find
out
when the podcast is going live usually
on Wednesdays between ten and one
another fish I tried to get up but I
just wasn't feeling well you could hear
it in my voice I'm still not feeling
well for my trip I'm on Twitch I love
twitch um Eric Griffin gaming you want
to interact with me come there we have a
good time there you know and you could
be a subscriber on Twitch that's a way
to support the show you could be a
YouTube member
um that's another great way I see some
YouTube members here thank you for being
here you can also be a patreon member
but you know I suggest one of the other
ones too because I just I don't know I'm
trying to do what I I can't figure out
the best thing for that you know because
it's just it just feels like I do a lot
here it's just like support me here but
I don't even know I'm trying to figure
it out
whatever you guys got if you got some
ideas you know hit me up with your ideas
all right
um let's see here uh
uh what are we doing oh yeah today's
show is brought to you by door Dash
doordash get 50 off your first doordash
order up to ten dollar value when you
use code
rwg Refuge Griffin rwg at checkout
limited time offer terms apply
so I want to thank doordash
anyways guys
um let's see I'm glad you're uh here
this week you know thanks for all you
know everybody that's in here live every
week or sometimes you're just catching
it for the first time this is riffen
with Griffin comedy News sports podcast
basically just my inner thoughts
sometimes they're funny sometimes
they're introspective sometimes they're
serious but they're always authentically
me if you're new if you're old and
you've been here before you know you
know the deal thanks for being here and
it is what it is which should be the
name of my podcast it is what it is
you know y'all always got some crap to
say
um let's go right into comments let's go
right in the comments
um you know last week last week was a a
big episode well not a big episode but
it's kind of controversial episode
because I was talking about Don Lemon
and the Tucker Carlson being fired and
then there was like some transgender
topics so like I got it like the ads
were like they messed up my ads which is
like so ridiculous did I find that
YouTube is now censoring people you know
what I'm saying I think you know it's
like there's supposed to be this like
place where you could just put your
content up and you don't care about you
know the the you know the the
established media places that are not
giving people the chance you know
especially like for comedy especially
like if YouTube is going to start
censoring
what they think is like inappropriate or
whatever for for the the comics you know
and of course I'm not talking about you
know somebody just being completely out
of pocket you know what I mean but if we
can't discuss sensitive topics
especially in the way I discuss them I'm
not bashing anybody or anything like
that so if you're gonna censor me I
can't imagine
you know you're putting out a comedy
special on YouTube and then YouTube is
going to be like oh you know you said
jokes about this so we're gonna like you
know uh you know we're gonna like uh you
know Shadow ban it or whatever like that
then that's gonna be a real issue and I
think that that's gonna like you know
push the power back to
you know
Netflix HBO and places like that in
terms for comedy you know and in terms
of podcasting it's like hopefully at
least you can still see it so like if
you're a fan of people and you're not
getting notifications from your favorite
podcasts and you're wondering boom you
know you really should look like go to
their channels and stuff because you'd
be surprised uh you know that because I
think this is happening a lot especially
like you know especially coming off of
like the pandemic even if you say that
word they flag it it's like oh here
comes some news about you know it's like
coming off of that and all the stuff
that we're finding out now and they're
just trying to I feel like we're being
suppressed you know I really feel like
they don't want people talking about
stuff you know I mean it's weird
excuse me
um so anyways so that was like that just
I mean for that last episode so you know
so let's go to some comments uh Christy
love I appreciate all the good advice uh
he gives but all dissing and ragging on
him
does is very cringe stop telling all the
business all your business these women
love going to this Matt Rife episode
from two years ago now that he's so
popular and they just love get you know
I don't understand it I mean I guess I
do understand it you know what I mean so
it's like all right Christy you know
whatever
um Tony Guzman love you montesi people
you know Montez will I'll be Montez
forever it's all right
here's another one another girl like all
my new girl followers or people watching
my podcast it's all about Matt Rife
here's another one uh let's see this has
to be my favorite interview with Matt
love how genuine it is
so crazy
now here's a comment I have to read
Because this is one of these backhanded
like I find it so ridiculous comment
that somebody left okay some but I'm
gonna read it because I have a comment
about this comment Eric I would love to
watch your podcast more but the cast
isn't as interesting in long form maybe
switch it up and do 20 minute type of
solo rants like you do now uh now and
longer uh form ones when you have guests
just my opinion
this is what I have to say about this a
a comment from I don't even know what
his name is Chet so or cheat so whatever
just turn it off when you don't want to
watch anymore
you know what I mean
I actually put time stamps so if you
want to go to my podcast and you just
want to hear NBA news time stamp to NBA
watch that segment and bounce
why should I
only do 20 minutes like if you don't
want to watch the whole thing
don't watch the whole thing
you know what I mean like this is the
least constructive comment this is one
of these like the world revolves around
me comment
you know what I mean just do what I want
it to be like you going like you see
something and you go hey you know I
don't really want to watch your your
television show for an hour
um can you make it 10 minutes instead
because then I'll watch it
it's like
hey people don't even think they just
write [__] you know
John's song
I mean he starts it took you this long
to realize you can't trust mainstream
media let alone blatantly political
biased news networks wow
[Laughter]
I'm doing a podcast man I'm talking
about what's happening now
the fact that you don't know that wow
uh foreign
now
I got a lot of comments last week about
my comments on Tucker Carlson even on my
other podcast on um golden hour you know
I really got I got to me a lot of like
misinformed comments about what I'm
saying what I was asking you know I mean
here's the thing
I don't mind you have comments on me you
have your own opinions do you but don't
misinterpret what I'm saying that's all
don't misinterpret what I'm saying to
make it out to be what you want if you
don't understand what I'm saying then
you might want to ask you'd be like or
or and say hey this is my opinion about
this but like when people try to
misinform what I'm saying no
because I got a lot of dumb to me it's a
lot of dumb scary Actually I don't even
want to say dumb I got a lot of
frightening responses from people about
this and you could tell they're sort of
like conservative leaning like it's kind
of like this thing where they're like uh
like they don't care you know they're
just like so what you know so what Taco
Carlson was lying to us or misleading us
making us believe that we were on the
same Pages you know so what it doesn't
matter you know it's like I think it
does matter and that was my whole
question is how do you feel that this
person presented to you that you that he
was on the same page if you're a trump
supporter if you believed that the
election was a rick you know you
believed all that stuff
how does it make you feel that the
number one news person that this person
who was the most popular on that Network
was portraying one thing to you and
secretly didn't really believe that
that's all I'm asking
I don't care if if
I just think how does that make you feel
if you think like well it doesn't make
me feel anything like you know this
ain't about right or left for me I just
think that I would want to know how that
makes you feel if you know you know what
I mean like it's just to me if I
supported if I was a trump supporter
and then like I I was getting rah-rah
you know like every night I watched
Tucker Carlson and I'm like
excuse me damn it my throat man
if I'm watching Tucker Carlson every
night and I'm like finally here's a guy
who's on the same page as me here's a
guy that I can listen to and I know you
believe he has Integrity you believe
that he is speaking your truth
and you come to find out that he was
just he didn't he don't really believe
it
you know or and that
you know the money was so great that he
just kind of compromised his beliefs and
you can even be on his side for terms of
that but just like it'll make you feel
anything like you just have to attack me
that's what it makes you do like it
makes you go oh well you don't blah blah
blah you know oh you don't oh so what he
was making like this is the scariest
comment I got and it was on the golden
hour thing
some guy goes you know
oh it doesn't matter man he's making
content content
if you believe that that shit's scary
that if you are okay with the news
organization making content like a tick
tock star
wow
I would feel some kind of way about that
but this thing just you're not supposed
to be making content you're supposed to
be reporting on the news
or in in like Sean Hannity Tucker
Carlson and those kind of people's case
commenting giving us opinion on the news
the truth
that's what I think
a news organization is supposed to be
doing
so if you just want to gloss over it and
be like
come on Griffin they're making content
so what that he doesn't believe it
I I can we just put politics aside and
stop you know like so many people are
like are trying to attack me like don't
attack me we're trying to have a
discussion about you know like this one
idiot is all on me on my thing talking
about oh well you know you vote right
you know you vote Democrat [__] I have
never said what I've you don't know what
I vote for you don't know anything about
me like that and if if you think that I
don't look at the thing and go oh I like
this person better than that person you
don't know me at all
you know what I mean and to make that
assessment because that's that's what's
that's why Taco Carlson and those guys
just make up [__] because people like
that they just go oh well you know these
people are going to believe what they
believe no matter what that [__] pissed
me off man I just just don't
misinterpret what you think I am just
we're just discussing how does this make
you feel like I want people to really go
huh maybe your answer is I don't make me
feel anything I don't care you know I
still feel what I feel I still support
Trump I still support what maybe you
feel like that someone else might be
like and that was disappointing it was
disappointing I I want I that's what I
was trying to get from people like tell
me what you feel about this
that's all
you know what I mean it's like you can
still be conservative all you want you
can still believe in all but I just feel
like if the main sorts of news that you
because because believe me everything
else is liberal there are way more
liberal news outlets popular news
outlets than there are conservative Fox
News was the number one news Outlet the
most popular news Outlet there's other
ones like daily wire which I now
subscribe to because I want to hear
other sides and stuff right anyways
and then the people on there secretly
are texting each other
you know opposite of what they're saying
on the air
how does that make you feel that's all
you know what I mean
anyways
right more comments
let's see
um let me see another one here
let's see okay some Jay Jason it was
awesome seeing Eric on Lopez versus
Lopez he crushed it thank you
uh let's see
um I don't know this there's a lot of
other ones
the mixed what is this the mixed metal
head I think it's his name yeah mixed
metal head I love your podcast man gets
me through the day I like the way you
address politics both sides are filled
with all kinds of buffoonery I I wish
more people could see the moderate side
of the Democrat and Republican views
rather than the extremes thank you
that's exactly how I feel everything's
always got to be extremes man
here's light the way wrote I feel that
we can still have democracy without two
opposing sides let's get rid of the
Democratic and Republican party and just
have all for one one for all type of
government labeling teams is really
killing us both killing both sides you
know what I couldn't agree more or let's
have more voices in there and there are
they're just not popular you know when
you go look at like your presidential
ballot you'll see like 10 people and
you'll be like who's this
you know what I mean it'll be like from
some green party and uh Libertarians and
there's all these other people that are
running but we just never hear about it
because the mainstream media is just
extreme left extreme right and I I don't
like that either so good comment there
um
somebody just got virtual K9 said Tucker
for life okay I feel you you know uh
actually I don't I don't know if you you
should I I saw this
um
Twitter thing that Tucker did he did a
video like after being fired and what he
was talking about I was like oh yeah
like now I think if he's just gonna be
an independent Source without somebody
that telling him what to say and do or
pressuring him to like whatever I think
he might be a great watch you know what
I mean like I hope he really comes out
with all his feelings now because I
don't mind a person that is conservative
I don't mind a person that has a
conservative Viewpoint about like
specially fiscally conservative stuff a
person that you know
pick yourself off your bootstraps and
you know work hard and you know limited
government I mean these are cons like
there's there's nothing wrong with
conservative Concepts man and so if you
have a voice that's going to talk about
that without it having to be this sort
of like Left Right agenda thing he might
be good man so let's see anyways enough
comments
thank you everyone for all your comments
you know what I mean so now let me take
off my headphones
because I want to talk about
I went to Austin this weekend
Austin Austin we
had it cowboys
possum in the gun bush
um and so shout out to smance check out
smance on Twitch fantastic gamer
he got me this hat
he got me to say he actually got
matching hats for me and Rachel first of
all let me tell you something that
Rachel did so what I didn't know is my
boy samance out in Austin he hit up
Rachel on Instagram and was like Hey I
want to buy Eric a cowboy hat you know
what I mean can you tell me his size
and Rachel being Rachel was like oh well
here's his size but you know what would
be really great is if you got me a hat
too like it can't just be about me
you know what I mean so this woman and
so all right and I didn't know this and
he didn't tell me right so then I he he
shows up with the hats and I'm like oh
man this is great man thank you you know
what I mean and I look you know I'm a
hat guy now look at that that looks good
it ain't bad huh
and it ain't bad right and so
I get home and I want to surprise Rachel
and I'm like babe turn around you know I
take it out of my bag I put my hat on
and then I'm holding her hat and she
turns around and she's like oh yay
you're right but then she tells me she's
like well I already knew
you already knew you got me doing this
whole surprise thing and you already
knew I mean
I'm telling you man the fact that she
made the dude by by her a hat
that's women y'all
there's a new sheriff in town y'all and
his name's Sheriff Griffin
[Music]
this should be a country version it's
real fan with Griffin
on a country road
right there we're Griffin in a truck
anyways
sorry man my voice my it's my sinuses
man I I don't know
anyways all right so I want to talk
about
I went to the Mothership in Austin and
shout out to Joe Rogan what a great Club
this is man if you're ever passing
through the Austin area you got to go
check this club out I've been doing
comedy for 20 plus years I've been to
most clubs all over the country
and the vibe and everything about this
club it's it it's it's it's it's the
best Cub Club in the country but you
know it's new right so of course you
know it is but I'm not gonna take
anything away from it so
you know I got
Yeah man so here's some pictures from
the mothership I mean the attention to
detail that's the Green Room so if
you're listening right now you gotta go
watch
in the green room they have they have
two different groups they got this main
room called the fat man and this other
room called the little boy which is like
a smaller room holds like 75 or so and
the main room holds like 250 but just
like all this art on the wall all the
attention to detail it's really great
like that's in the Green Room a little
sign right there says Get It Together
[__] that's so Joe Rogan if you know
him you know it's called the mothership
so there's like sort of like alien
artwork all over the place and it's just
like there's this bar called mitzi's
which is named after Mitzi short The
Comedy Store and the bar is this
beautiful thing that's what the the
from the balcony the view of the main
room looks like that's in the green room
they have this great bar and like all
these great pictures and it's just like
you know it's clean and and the lines
are great and like you know and so I
don't know I just I really had a great
time it was five sold out shows you know
and I was like man you know and
what I like about the club and what Joe
Rogan the fact that someone like Joe
Rogan made this club is because one he's
got more money than God right well he
got a lot of money for a comic you know
what I mean you know he's gonna be a
billionaire one day you know what I'm
saying and so he made this club you know
he's like Willy Wonka you know what I
mean he's got this this amazing stuff
that goes on in there and they got all
the you know so anyway my point is this
he's not doing this to make money
you know this is not a this is a thing
he's like he cares about comedy he cares
about the comedy community
he's building a reputation at his club
that he's saying to the people in this
city I am going to give you a great show
these are people I think are really
funny and they're going to be on my
stage and then the people in that City
can go you know what let's go see who's
there
as opposed to a lot of Clubs
they don't care about building the
reputation in their City anymore all
they care about is making money and
that's fine if that's your business
model that's fine if you want to be a
club owner a manager that all you care
about is making money like then that's
fine I have no I I have no problem with
you doing that but overall I have it I
have to just say then you don't care
about the comedy community
that you don't care about building
Comics up care about bringing a great
show to your city based off your
reputation as a comedy club now all you
care about is just making money so then
they're that then you're gonna have Tick
Tock stars on stage you're gonna have
people that don't care about the art
form on stage because you're like I
gotta sell tickets I gotta sell tickets
and you it's supposed to be two-way
because the business has turned into a
lot of places and they're run by
[__] I'm not going to do any names
because hey I'm still in the business
but they know they [__] they're
[__] all their care oh you know all
they care about is ticket counts and
drink sales and all this stuff and
there's no building up the young comedy
community or even
establishing a great reputation so I
have a problem with that
you know I really I really I really just
have a problem with that that's just I'm
not for that I just think that there
should be a mix because a lot of times
now the comedy clubs are just all about
like well what's your social media
following and can you get people on your
social media following to come to our
club and then it's just all about that
so then you just got big podcasters and
you know whatever you know popular
people and then there's nothing about
the comedy the comedy anymore right
where it doesn't matter you know and I
get that tune and I'm not necessarily
saying there's anything wrong with that
because these people haven't connected
with their audience you know like if
you're like you got a big podcast and
people have connected with you they want
to come see you they they like your
sensibility and they're watching you but
that's not the art form I'm just saying
remember the art form
remember people
you get what I'm saying I hope you guys
understand what I'm saying so would love
to hear your comments about that but I
just want to say again shout out to Joe
Rogan
absolutely fabulous Club
it really is a good time oh and here's
something that they do that I really
love
and I was talking about it with some of
the comics there
they lock up your phone so they have
these phone things that are locked up
and you can't get to your phone
you know while you're at the club you
know it's locked in a box in a little
bag but I forgot what the things are
called but your phone is locked up and
you can't watch the phone let me tell
you what this does to the show it makes
people engage
it makes people when they're walking in
the club now that their phone is gone
they're actually engaging with each
other they're actually looking at other
people and they're being like wow this
is a shared experience shared Community
experience right now
and I think that's so important for the
show any show
come and watch the show
don't look at your phone
don't try to take pictures don't try to
like oh let me see what's going on next
when you can actually sit in made for
better energy
it just made for better shows I really
felt connected with the crowd in a way
that I haven't felt in a long time
because it wasn't little lights in the
show I wasn't worried about some Karen
like oh let me film this because this
joke sounds like it's going to be
something that I can get him in trouble
for or something like you don't have to
worry about none of that it was great so
shout out to Joe Rogan once again for a
fantastic experience and you know
I hope you guys
uh get a chance to see that club all
right
and you know like I said I'm a hat guy
now right so I don't know this how does
this look on me y'all you know in the
comments I have another hat I'm gonna
put on after this but before we get to
that
let's get to our sponsor door Dash
excuse me damn it
doordash what I love about doordash is
not just about getting food from a
restaurant anymore you know if you're
missing syrup for your pancakes you just
made some good pancakes and you're like
oh man we don't got no syrup
you go on doordash now and you can get
that kind of stuff you ran out of your
favorite coffee creamer doordash grocery
delivery you can get what you want right
now when you need it if you love the
convenience of getting what you want
right to your door with doordash grocery
delivery you can stock up for the week
or order last minute Cravings
conveniently
hey you can get toast avocados you know
what I mean it's just really making it
like a a place that you can get what you
need fast when you need it conveniently
from your home
you've trusted door Dash to deliver your
favorite restaurants now you can get
groceries that are really delivered that
actually you can get grocery delivery
that's delivered right to you with
thousands and thousands of grocery
stores to choose from you'll find the
best in your neighborhood and boost your
local economy which is that that's
another thing that's great about
doordash all your favorite restaurants
are your favorite little grocery stores
around here it's great
easy substitutions right in the app and
the Best in Class customer support
doordash delivers groceries exactly how
you want it
get 50 off your first doordash order up
to ten dollar value when you use code
rwg at checkout limit time offer term
Supply that's 50 off ten dollars on a 15
minute 15 minimum sub total and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code rwg don't forget
that's code rwg stands for riffle
Griffin from 50 off first order with
doordash
foreign
man sorry my
my sinuses are just on fire right now
y'all hold up oh
man that's terrible lives lives not on
camera
all right anyways
thanks for being here
this is what happens when you do
this is what happens when you do a live
podcast
and then you're not feeling well
it happens but The Show Must Go On so
anyways I'm a hot guy now all right
let's get to some of the stuff that's
going on that I wanted to talk about
y'all first up
the Met Gala is back
the Met Gala is back y'all and it is as
crazy as it's always been like look at
some of this nonsense that people are
wearing man like check out Rihanna and
ASAP Rocky like I don't know I mean are
they
are they the ones
uh you know I mean Jenny Ortega looks
great but it's like what is this stuff
cardi B looking like an evil witch I
don't know what that is now the one that
gets me is Pascal man I don't know if
y'all can see that one but wait let me
see if I could
let me open the image in a new window so
we could just see this like bro
[Laughter]
no thank you with this look
I can't have you looking like my
Gardener from the neck up just so every
man Blue Collar you know you know what I
mean like you looking like you own a a
construction company and then you got
your construction knees out and shorts
with a with a long ass jacket like this
is this is terrible this is
like he don't even look comfortable in
this
you know like you know what I'm saying
he don't even look comfortable and his
knobby ass knees need to be covered up
oh whatever I know whatever the guy's
name is okay whatever the rapper's name
is you guys
[Laughter]
you guys are always on me about stuff
okay whatever all right you get it
calling me old I mean some of the women
like some of this stuff looks like all
right this is cool but there was some
weirder stuff you know how do you say
the guy's name it's not ASAP
it's not as soon as as soon as possible
Rocky I thought that was his name
uh
you know yeah so there's uh what's her
face Jenny Ortega I mean he looks crazy
um who is this
oh Gigi Hadid oh she's like some big
model I don't find her all that you know
what I mean I don't know I don't get it
that's maybe that's just me
um here is the Kendall Jenner like what
what are you going
are you
are you Cinderella are you in the swim
team for the Olympics like pick
something woman pick it okay are you
what are you are you a superhero or you
know what I mean like what is this
outfit man
oh my God Kim Kardashian
like girl letting go like this I don't
even know what the hell that is that
don't even make no sense that one don't
make sense ooh and Hathaway okay girl
this was nice you know I don't know what
that dress is you know do you wear this
out and put like this wow oh that's
that's Versace
oh that's the woman that does all the
things you would think that she would
look better damn
Versace like is it me or is her head
like
seven for seven percent bigger than
everybody else's head
is that me
like damn dude
like she got a big ass head
[Laughter]
but that
that looks weird Okay so let's see who
was okay so here's this is Doja cat I
guess she's a rapper
right she's that one that always sounds
weird like her rap voice she got a very
distinct thing she is dressed like a cat
okay
all right
um I guess
Doja cat
shaped like a cat Okay dressed like a
cat I mean thank you Selma Hayek bring
us some adultness
being the one adult at the Met Gala okay
she has this beautiful red dress on okay
so that I forgot that there's people
listening that you might you're gonna
have to go to my YouTube also check that
thing out just to see this part okay all
right here we go here we go little Nas X
and here's the thing that gets me it
says he's in Dior what's Dior about this
is it the paint what's Dior the shoes
what is this dude doing what
why would you come to a an event in a in
a silver Speedo whatever that is
completely covered in silver looking
like Silver Surfer
this guy looks like Prince and Silver
Surfer had a baby you know what I mean
I don't know about this I get it though
you know do you I mean this is like Lady
Gaga or something Lady Gaga could do
this kind of craziness he's the guy
that's doing that and it's like you know
it's like rap business which is so toxic
masculinity kind of thing that people
say I don't agree with that but it you
know you know what I mean though there's
that feeling that you know hip-hop you
know before was just like you know and
then now you I don't know it just this
looks weird
I don't know about this
I don't understand this dude at all
okay
listen Kylie Jenner
she phoned okay let's just say what it
is y'all Kylie Jenner got it I don't
care what she's done I don't care about
the work she's done the work she's done
this is the work you should do you know
what I mean like you know what these
people it's like oh she don't really
look like that she got work done hey let
me tell you something the work she got
done is like putting up it's like
putting rims on an S-Class Mercedes it's
still dope off the lot Okay so
it is what it is she looks great who's
this
Aubry Plaza oh good for her ex she used
to be like she was a comic you know what
I mean and now she's doing a lot of
stuff she's in a lot of movies lately a
lot of good movies good for her she
normally don't have a smile on her face
I think she's usually like just like
stoic person but you could her smile
right now you can tell she's like a
little uncomfortable like oh my God I'm
at the Met Gala being sexy good for you
girl
um Bad Bunny I don't get this guy he's
another one I don't know if I even heard
one maybe I've heard one of his songs
but I wouldn't even know but he's like
he's like a super popular dude right now
right everybody's always talking about
this guy Bad Bunny so I don't know
sounds like a girl's name too if I think
bad bad bunny I would think
I don't know this crazy crazy outfit
okay who's this
Oh Billy eilish I mean now she is right
on brand you know what I mean damn Billy
Alex got a big ass head too right
yeah so she's you know she is who she is
consummate artist shout out to Billy
eilish not I'm not a fan of her music
but I'm a fan of her Artistry
um who's this I don't even know Olivia
Rodrigo I don't even know who this is
you know weird okay okay here we go
Bradley Cooper
thank you thank you Bradley Cooper thank
you just a regular ass tuxedo he look
out of place he looked at him he looked
like somebody's one of these Doja cats
gonna throw her keys yeah can you put my
car in the back that's what he looks
like compared to everybody else classic
look good for you Bradley Cooper
Gisele Bunsen okay good for you girl
still fine as hell damn Tom Brady why'd
you give this up
there's a class she's aging really
nicely graceful aging
still beautiful I don't know this looks
like I don't like this outfit though but
who am I to comment of course Pete
Davidson has to come like okay Pete
whatever Pete Davidson is Pete Davidson
it is what it is you know what I mean
what are we supposed to say about Pete
Davidson you know
and check out uh who is this uh
Priyanka Chopra and Jonas
oh Jonas and Nick Jonas oh they married
man wow
she's a ginormous woman you know I don't
mean fat I mean like she's thick right
compared to are he just a little dude
don't you you know what I mean don't it
look like she can whoop his ass
I don't know about Nick Jonas and his if
that's his wife man they're the weird
looking couple Cara Del Vinci or
whatever her name is the one that was
like you know on drugs or something like
that this is a ridiculous outfit she she
looks like she's in them like that looks
like a Marvel character outfit like you
know whatever girl
you know what let's shout out to lizzo
looking like actually it looked like she
even lost a few pounds good for her
lizzo has to slowly lose weight because
she she loses a lot of weight like Adele
did people are gonna just she's gonna
get vilified but it looks like she's a
little she looks healthier and you know
this outfit is trash though you know
what I mean like it's not on her this
outfit would look trash on anybody like
what is that I don't get it but shout
out to lizzo you know I mean you look
good girl good for you uh Nicole Kidman
and Keith Urban I didn't know they were
a couple but he looks a little like she
likes little men Nicole Kidman she loves
little men because this dude look how
little he is she is standing on the step
below granted she has on heels but she
looks like she Nicole Kidman can only be
with dudes she can post up on the
basketball court I think
you know what I mean
all right and then there's just a lot of
other ones that you guys can go check
out but you know for the most part
everybody look crazy
[Laughter]
you know what I mean everybody looks
crazy but shout out to the Met Gala
people so I don't know so there's that
you know I like to talk about everything
you know how we do it
um all right let's get into some wow I'm
running out of time really going in
today so I don't know how you feel about
this hat but Rachel bought me another
hat let's put on my other hat now
foreign oh this one I like it oh oh oh
wait how I look in this hat ah you gotta
turn it to the side just a little bit
right I mean I can't put it forward then
I look like I'm delivering I don't know
is it forward or do I give it a little
tilt what do y'all think uh what's up
let me hit you with a little pose bam
all right so this is my other hat
uh so
excuse me
all right let's talk about the NBA real
quick y'all
NBA is so good right now the playoffs
are excellent
so last night you had all right first of
all if you've been watching this on my
NBA talk you already know so let's go to
Celtics
Sixers
so James Harden who has been vilified
for so long for choking in the playoffs
Joel embiid the reigning MVP now shout
out to Jewel and B congratulations he
had a really great heartfelt response
when he won the MVP to see a big seven
foot guy like that cry and really show
how passionate he is about the game that
was great so
shout out to uh children B so he's out
James Harden shows up
45 points bunch of rebounds and assists
the dude
showed like hey I am a Hall of Famer
former MVP
I need to step up in this moment and he
did
but this to me is more about the Celtics
I told y'all when I've been talking
about the NBA playoffs I don't believe
in the Celtics coach Missoula I don't
believe in him I don't think he knows
how to make adjustments yet I don't
think he has enough experience to to get
these sort of young stars to get the
best out of them he's not motivating
them properly that that was a travesty
of a game there's no way they should
have lost that game
when they've had the best record
throughout the season and to lose a game
without the MVP of the league playing on
the other team in the playoffs at home
that was a travesty so I don't see the
subjects winning this series
I think if Jordan B comes back and I
think he is coming back tonight for
tonight's game I think the Sixers are
going to win this series in six or seven
so there's that now you got the Knicks
and the heat two teams that to me they
don't deserve I I shouldn't say that
deserve I don't think they're good
enough to win the championship
but man they playing like like the heat
you got to give it up to the Heat
organization
they were in the championship in the
bubble Jimmy Butler is like you know
playoff Jimmy do have 56 the other night
he got hurt he didn't play and you would
think then that the Knicks were just
gonna like
run over them in the next game
the heat were bawling
they're disciplined they play great
defense
like the Heat or just that team man so
you gotta look out for them
I just don't think they're good enough
to beat the good teams
and the Knicks got great performances
from like you know three or four of
their players and still barely won so
that's gonna be a series that's going to
go long but I'm not excited about the
Knicks or the heat but good games
on the other side
the Denver Nuggets are letting people
know why they are the best team in the
West
and the Joker two-time MVP is the truth
okay I hope they sweep the Suns
because I'm tired of Kevin Durant
just the the polarizing
presence of Kevin Durant everywhere he
goes and this idea that he's supposed to
be better than he really is you know
what I mean like maybe this is who he is
maybe he's the player that choked again
in OKC against LeBron in the finals that
choked against Golden State when they
were up 3-1 and then he goes to Golden
State joins the 72 win team he wins you
know then his playstyle can shine
because he's in a great organization
around great players and maybe Steph
Curry is way better than we give him
credit for is the reason why they won
those championships he gets the MVPs and
now we're like invalidates him like oh
he's the best then he goes back to
normal
goes to the Nets gets injured again they
can't win and then gets swept by the
Celtics now he leaves again and now he's
in the Suns where we're like oh okay now
he's on a good team Kevin Durant's going
to show us Devin Booker is playing
better okay he's just scoring more all
right and that's probably because of his
presence I granted that but still
production wise they're now down O2
and they were favored to win the
championship going into the playoffs I
hope the Denver Nuggets sweep them so we
could stop talking about this dude okay
get out of here all right
it could just be that's who he is and
then then we just move on with our lives
all right
now the series I want to talk about the
Lakers and Golden State Warriors
Lakers put it on
Memphis like Memphis get out of here
I hear they're not resigning Dylan books
whatever they're trying to blame him for
everything it don't matter
all right Lakers there's so much on the
line with this Lakers
Golden State matchup LeBron versus Steph
Curry
arguably now the best
team players and individual players of
the last 10 years
Steph Curry now has four championships
okay
the first one
we all know that the Cleveland Cavaliers
probably would have won that if they had
Kyrie and Kevin Love but it is what it
is they got that one so that one had a
little asterisk by it Kevin Durant comes
for the next two to me Asterix buy it
but last year
Steph Curry showed like oh wait he
actually might be a top five top ten
player of all time he put it he he
Finals MVP they won because of him cut
to this year game seven
dude at 50. and now we're looking at him
like wow at 35 years old however old he
is
scored 50 and he's the greatest shooter
ever okay
and they say all the time out he's
changed the game
to me not for the better because Steph
Curry is masterful at shooting he's the
greatest shooter ever
all y'all to think you can shoot like
Steph Curry you can't
that's what's wrong with it
like
Trey young look if you look at Trey
Young's numbers his shooting percentage
it's not good he's hurting his team and
he's one of these people that you go is
influenced by Steph Curry
Jordan Poole in the last the Laker law
Laker win Jordan pool takes a 35 foot
three-point shot and misses it nobody's
in front of him he could have dribbled
twice and took a better shot
that influence is Steph Curry
if he would have made it we would have
been like yay we would have given Steph
Curry praise to you see the influence no
that's the influence dudes like Jordan
Poole think they're Steph Curry and they
take stupid shots in moments that they
shouldn't
that's what's wrong with it okay but
anyways so I don't want to hear like
that's his influence Steph instead and
you're not Steph Curry we need to start
putting more respect on Steph Curry he
is actually way better than we think and
a way better shooter than we give him
credit for because it's not like because
we think shooting is something you could
just practice and do that's why all
these idiots in the NBA think they can
shoot 35 Footers you're not Steph Curry
take your dumb ass in and shoot a better
shot in a in a in a very important
first you know
you know first game of the series
anyways
this means so much for both guys
whoever wins this if whoever can go on
and win the championship they would have
one more Championship than the other we
already consider LeBron James number one
a one B to Jordan or you think Jordan's
the best and then you think LeBron is
second or vice versa right we already
put him in that category
but
this is showing like maybe we think
Steph Curry's better right now and
granted the dude's 39 years old and he's
20 years in the league so it's like
there's all those factors but that's
just not how people are going to think
the narrative is going to be Steph
Curry's better if he wins and it's like
it's great man that's what I think it's
great for basketball I'm so glad it's
Lakers versus Golden State Warriors you
know so we'll see it means so much for
their legacies I've said this last week
I think that if LeBron James could take
this team and win the championship he
will have like I think he'll beat a goat
I think even Jordan people would be like
damn at 39
11 times to the finals five
championships it's gonna be hard to not
make LeBron James a goat it's gonna be
hard all us Jordan guys are really gonna
have to take a deep look at ourselves
and be like wow [__] this is gonna be
serious so and then you have Steph Curry
who would have five championships like
how about this with five championships
is Steph Curry better than Kobe you know
on the all time list is he better than
uh Tim Duncan do you put him ahead of
you know what I'm saying like Steph
Curry's putting himself in a position
where you're like damn this dude's way
better than we think right so I love
that Series so anyway we'll see what
happens that's that
so we'll see man you know hey you can
laugh all you want you know I see
somebody in the chat talking about he's
not winning it though and laughing like
I don't think you watch NBA then
anything can happen right now like the
Lakers have a really good team the way
uh Lakers have a really good team and
the Warriors just have they have great
players and great experience
through one of these teams because
there's no clear favorite in the in the
in the playoffs right now every team has
some flaws so I think any of the teams
not not any of them these are the teams
I think can win the championship right
now Lakers Warriors Denver Nuggets
um
Sixers
Celtics
in that order too
no no I think the order goes Denver
first I think Denver has the best chance
to win then to me it's Lakers
Celtics Warriors
yeah so I don't know it's like none of
these teams are like clear favorites
they all got some flaws
and at any given time whoever is the
best player on the court can have a game
that could change the whole thing so
keep a look out I'm Gonna Keep continue
to talk about the playoffs as it goes on
all right
all right y'all last thing I want to
talk about
and you know what I wanted to talk about
some other things but do we run it out
of time I'll go back to those things
next week but I want look I am a huge
American Idol fan
I love American Idol
and I want to talk about the final
um what do you call it
the final singers in American Idol right
now the top eight
I watch American Idol every year for the
past like I don't know how many years
this might be the best Collective group
of singers
and Artistry okay because it's more than
just singing what does it mean to be
American Idol to be a star
and these people got it
okay wait where is it
wait what the hell is going on here I
just had it
I'll read more here we go all right so
this guy Zechariah Smith not a fan okay
he's great and all he can sing good but
I don't he I just don't connect with him
not a fan of Zechariah Smith I don't
think he's going to win I don't think he
has a chance in hell to win American
Idol all right I've watched American
Idol enough to know
who has a chance to win and why this guy
he will not win American Idol okay boom
done now this chick Haven Madison
she's got the Artistry she's like this
young 17 year old girl that writes her
own songs you know she got that Vibe of
like that Billy eilish Taylor Swift kind
of thing she got you know what I mean
but her voice just isn't strong enough
but her vibe is like there the American
Idol stardom she got it like she's gonna
be a star like she's gonna leave this
and go on and you're gonna hear about
her right she has a slight chance to win
the show
for some reason women don't do well on
American Idol all right and whatever
that is and that's something I think is
going against her but she's great
beautiful
here's what I like about her
she's she like she looks like she's she
got a good family background right so
she's presenting herself in a way that's
not coming off like she's not over
sexualizing herself it really she really
does come off as a sweet girl artist and
you see a classic Beauty that's not like
you know we're not pushing a thing you
know what I mean love her now this chick
I don't even know how to say her name
she got that idle thing but to me it's
too much like it's too cocky but she's
great she's a great vocalist
she got that star quality she knows how
to put on a show but it seems too broad
wayish you know what I mean like it
seems to like contrived but she has a
chance to win like her
this dude
he got that country thing y'all Warren
pay or however you say his name he
country as hell and he got it
he got it you know he like you may not
think he's the best singer you may not
think he has the star quality but he got
that thing that wins American Idol I
would not be surprised if he wins
because he got the confidence and he got
that thing so
I like that
somebody said you don't have a hat
friendly head and face
wow what an [__] huh this is my not
just for that I'm wearing this all the
time now
it's a hat Rachel got me Rachel likes it
I don't know oh this guy uh em Ian tongi
oh my God the sweetest kid ever
he's got such a great story about his
father died he plays his dad's guitar
he's got a Milky voice
milky as hell man he's so lovable he's
so likable he has zero chance to win
American Idol I'm sorry
fat dudes just don't win the last one to
win I think was Reuben Studdard and
that's only because he was going up
against a gay guy
okay
it was the fat black guy versus the like
like Clay Aiken probably should have won
American Idol back in the day but that
at that time in society they weren't
ready for that okay but anyways
that's the same reason why I think uh
Adam Lampard didn't win too it's just
some biasedness but whatever this guy he
is not gonna win American Idol those
kids at home that vote and people that
vote they like what they like and this
ain't what they like okay
because when the last remember the big
black dude from last year I forgot his
name and R.I.P because he tragically
died in a car accident
he had the best voice of anybody in
American Idol in the last 10 years like
he really could sing he had no chance of
winning this poor kid
I think is going to be caught in that
Loop of
fashion style and and how people don't
like
people don't like fat people it's just
it is what it is you know there's a
shaming that goes on and I think that's
gonna work against him I would like to
see him win because I think he's got a
great story but it's like that's going
to be part of that
foreign
this kid Colin Style
he got a confidence issue he's just not
confident enough I don't think he's
gonna win but I wouldn't be surprised if
he did win because he's a good looking
kid but I don't think he sings all that
well and I think that like he just comes
across like he's not ready to be a star
you know but I can see him winning now
this lady right here Megan Danielle oh
my God she got it all in my opinion she
is a passionate great she's a great
singer she has a great look she got that
but she has a little bit of a confidence
issue too but you get goosebumps when
she sings and talks about stuff so I
would I would like to see her win too
this chick oh she was eliminated yeah I
didn't see her winning anyway this this
Asian kid he's a great singer but he
don't got the star quality he just yeah
he just he was missing something but
he's only 17. now here's my guy
Oliver Steele I actually hit him up on
Instagram and I I'm like no dude I think
you're gonna win I did think he was
gonna win early on because he's got that
thing white guy that plays guitar and he
sings he really is a great singer
Oliver
if you're listening
get your confidence up bro
you are great and you have to portray
that on stage he got he didn't get voted
in the judges saved him because they
know how great he is but he if he
doesn't get that star thing he he has to
sing with passion and really perform and
he's a little hesitant and I think
that's going to hurt him but he was my
favorite but he's no longer my favorite
to win right now unless he gets this
going what I'm saying so anyways guys
I want to thank you for uh you know
watching riffing with Griffin
you know we'll see what more hats what
other hats we can get
the other hats we can get on the show
you know because I'm a hat guy now I
don't care what you say
oh I think that they have like I think
there's like commercials
um
uh I don't know I think I clicked a
thing where commercials are coming on so
sorry if that happens but you know
you'll still get to see the whole show
it is what it is man you know this is my
this is a source of income for me too
it's not all free you know I mean you're
getting this good ass free content and
you guys complaining all the time it's
like damn you know it is what it is you
know enjoy the show but anyways I want
to thank everybody for watching
referendum Griffin for listening to
referral Griffin I appreciate you guys
as always
you know you guys come every week and it
just makes me feel special when people
hit me up and they're like yo I love
your podcast I listen to it every week
and that kind of stuff you know I don't
have a big audience but I have a I have
a great audience and I appreciate you
guys as always you know what I mean so
you know what time it is
[Music]
that rap recap time
ripping with Griffin
I'll be doing it again
tell your friend
what we do this week move your feet
[Music]
watch that NBA
Lakers going all the way
listen to what I say
[Music]
hey hey
[__] American Idol
watch it y'all
[Music]
watch that type 8
watch seven out of eight four
[Music]
the Met Gala
that rhymes with Gala thanks for
watching
this your favorite podcast
if you talk [__] in the comments
Coming For That Ass
next week
see you next week y'all
let me know what you think about the
hats
leave some comments let's have some
discourse and I can't wait
to see you next week thank you y'all
River with Griffin
foreign
[Music]